よろしくお願いします安間の撮影お疲れ様
でしたはい今回はどうでしたか出演されて
一体アマ何回出たか分からんけどさいつも
あれでおしまいよ相手はね全く話を聞く気
がないわけいかにして否定するかだけなん
よね出てきたあのつまらん連中なそうれ
必死になって言わせるやろだけどあれら
素人やもんでさ言えるのは体罰はいかん
体罰はいかんそこでおしまいよ体罰問題に
引きずりこんであの話聞いとるとさまるで
体罰なければいい教育ができるそう言っ
とるよね今はどうなの体罰全くなしで教育
しとるやろ落ちこぼればっかりできる
じゃんうちの教育は体罰だけではない教育
法何らかのソフトがあってやるんだから
その優劣を競よ連中はもうそういう教育法
のことは何にも言わんじゃんあれは言え
ない経験がないんやもんあれ見てたら
みんなじゃないとかいう人もおったけど
あれ全部リベラルやもんね言っとることが
だから日本全体がリベラルに毒されとるん
だあれ考えとこらんオム心理教が攻撃され
とる時にマスコミは兄弟の理科系のオ東大
の理科系の帯が麻原の弟子になったとこれ
は麻原に洗脳されたんだからけしからんと
いう自分はできるあ日本一の催を洗脳する
ことができるんかマスコミごとにはできん
よねだからあれは考えを変えや私も理科系
だからよく分かるんだけどリベラルの教育
を受けてるとなんかおかしいという気がし
てくるわね掛けはそうなんだ文化ははーと
こう取りすぎちまうかもしれんけどなで
それがなんかわからんのやで麻原翔は彼ら
のその思いを解放してやったやそれから
麻原が洗脳したんじゃなしにリベラルに
洗脳されとったのを麻原翔が解いてやった
んだそう考えるとすっきりするじゃんだ
から何十年代の疑問を解いてくれたこの人
は素晴らしい人だだから弟子になろうと
いうそういう順番よ
ねこの麻原はどうやってリベラルの洗脳を
解いたんですかねんなも口でいいやすぐ
解けるわさ理系はこの前の安で言ってた
じゃないや議論しばとか嘘よねあの女絶対
わからんあ女言ったいかん
な絶対わからんよねあの都合の悪いことが
言われるとヒステリ起こすからねそのいう
ことは理解できないよ
ね東大兄弟の理科系たちがリベラルの洗脳
を受けてたっていう部分についてなんです
けど何によってもしくは誰によってそう
いう洗脳って行われてると考えます小学校
からの教育じゃない小学校から徳育なんて
あったかなかったんよ育は悪いなんていう
一派が教育を握っとったんだだけど口で
言って得意ができるもんじゃない身につけ
んといかんのや1番いいのは正しい行動を
するこれが得意になるよねでいつも正しい
行動ができたらもうこれは下達したという
状態になっちゃうもんでそれに近づいて
いくんだこれ人間性が高まったっていう
やろ正しいことばっかりやる特にこう対人
関係でねお成人も言わないきれことも言わ
んお前バカだといえ
ばこれ得意できとるよね正直本音だから
本音で人と付き合いにはね大体嘘ばっかり
言っとるやろブスっつったらいかんのや
から非常にこう個性的なお顔してますねっ
ていうじゃんそんなこと言ってたら得意は
できんわ
ね学校の先生とかもリベラルで教育して
やろうみたいなのはあんまり思ってないの
かなって思ったんですけどその点はどう
ですかね学習指導要があるからさそれで
やったらリベラルになっちゃうしっては
いかんの体罰とんでもないとかいうあれは
リベラルのやり方ない学習指導要が
リベラルによって作られてるってことそう
そうそうそうそれが教育論じゃない
リベラルのデイデイ教育を未だに引きずっ
とるのは日本だけやろうなよそはみんな
捨てた効果がないからないでアメリカは
190何年かなレガンが捨てたんよね
こんな教育をやってたらアメリカが潰れる
だからもうこれはやめその代わり日本が
使ってた教育論にするというこれがレガン
のやり方や日本は日本でやってた教育論を
ダメだと言って捨ててそのとんでもない
教育論を維持し続けてだからレガンの言っ
た通りに日本今潰れかけとるじゃんそうし
たくなければ一刻も早くリベラルとも
追っ払うアメリカ行け言ったらええ日本
嫌いやろ愛国心はいかんて言うんだからだ
たらもアメリカ行って信じまということや
ねでて欲しいよねリベラル国賊やない
か校長的にはリベラルとはどんな人なん
ですか今日本全体がリベラルになってない
よう考えてこらん今日本はリベラル独裁だ
からあれはこうでないといかんあれはこう
でないといけない思想の自由だなんとかの
自由だと言ってんのにLGBTをダメって
言ったらそれは悪いやつなんだということ
になっちまう自由はない今日本のリベラ
ルっていうのはなんかこう平等主義という
のかねなんでも平等なんだってありえん
ことを言うわけ
よ平等主義の一番いかんのはね進歩が
なくなっちまう上があるから進歩するんや
でそれを上があってはいかんて言っとる
わけやからだからあれ今でも言っとるかな
みんな平等なんだからあるいは運動会で手
ついでゴールして全員一等っていうあれは
一等がええっていうこと知っとるから全員
一等なんやね差別しとるやないか一等とケ
とどっちが上だということ知っとるんや
ちゃんと差別しとるんやねそいつはいかん
のだ足の早いややる気なくすわねもっと
早くあろうと思わんわねあれいとになっ
たらもっと早くなろうと思うよね来年も
勝ったるぞという褒めて伸ばせと言ってん
のにああいうことについては褒めんのやね
おかしいやろその場その場でダブル
スタンダードトリプルスタンダードでね列
もいかんのだよ命令してはいかんね人間性
というのを全部否定しとるんやでその挙句
がナンバーワンよりオンリーワンやろあれ
矛盾だらけの歌やろナンバーワンと
オンリーワンて比べるものなのオンリー
ワンというのは状態を言っとるんだ
ナンバーワンていうのは結果を言っとるん
だ2つ比べてはいかんよそれなのに
ナンバーワンよりオンリーワンの方が価値
があるんだという歌やねで彼らあの年の
ナンバーワンになったやないかそれはえん
かなそれともナンバーワンになったけど僕
たち価値ありませんよったのかねそういう
人間性を無視したようなあんなこと
ばっかり言っとったら人間ダメなるさだ
からナンバーワンよりオンリーワンという
歌が流行るいかに社会が不健全かという
こと
や人間は競争によって進歩していきたいだ
から競争するというのは人間の本質へやつ
より上になろうとする価値が高くなろうと
するで実際に価値が高くなった時に幸福に
なるんよだから幸福になりたければ価値を
獲得すればいいつまり自分が進歩するそれ
なのに今は物で幸福になろうとするじゃん
物という価値を獲得したらやっぱり幸福に
なれるだけど特に子供は自分の行動を絡ん
でないよね親の金で買うんよだからもう1
つ幸福になれんのや自分の力じゃないから
ねから1番ええのはどんどんどんどん進歩
さして幸福だ幸福だを味わしといてある
ことよ一生幸福になれるからそれを物欲に
満たすことによって幸福にしょうというの
が今の風潮やろ子供にいろんなものてやる
女の子にも買ってやる女の方が物欲は強い
からね男がもらったよりも女がもらった方
が幸福感が大きいでそれを利用して男は女
を物にするわけやろそういうことができる
自分の力で幸福になろうよそのためには
目的を達成する行動が必要ないそういう
行動をさせるには不快感が必要なんやだ
から不快感がドンとくればそれを全部克服
して目的を生して幸福になれる
んところが今の教育見てごらん子供に不快
感を発生させることは悪いことになっとる
んやでもし発生したら助けてるんやね子供
進歩せんちゃん行動しないこれが今の教育
よ体罰もこれないんやで体罰をして子供に
不快感を発生させその不快感を乗り越える
行動をさせて幸せにするだから体罰がいか
んもう子供の幸せのどれだけか奪っちまっ
とるわねそういう風に考えよと体罰をし
たら子供が痛みを感ずる痛みを感ずるから
これは虐待だ虐待だから悪いことだこんな
馬鹿なこと考えるんじゃね人間はみんな
目的を持って行動するんやからね体罰だっ
て目的があるんだその目的が善ならば行動
も善なんだ目的が進歩なんだから子供の
体罰は全なんだリベラルていうのは進歩が
止まっちゃうんよ奴らほど理不尽のものは
ないわね
自分を守るために日本を滅ぼそうとしとる
日本を滅ぼしたら自分も滅びるんやで
そんなこともわからんわな彼らは自分だけ
は大丈夫という子供の頃を守ってもらった
時の癖が抜けんのや
なだからリベラルはダメなんです進歩が
ないやろ子供が進歩するのを邪魔しとる
やろ子供に苦痛を与えるから虐待だって
言っとったや予防者虐待やで歯なんか
なくさいかんよね手術もしたらいかんよね
ああいうとに文句ええよな自分の言うこと
が分かってない言ってることが分かって
ないその結果も想像できないだから
リベラルやれるんだいい加減なこと
ばっかり言っとりゃええんだきれこと言っ
てねブスに向かってあなたお綺麗ですねっ
てずっと言い続けてこら結婚迫られるよ
ええのやっぱり美人の方がええわけやろ
平等には扱わんやろ絶対平等じゃないと
いかんて言っとる人の男やったら奥さん女
やったらてじーっと見てみたいわね
やっぱり少しでもええや選ぶやろ同じ程度
かなと思ったら金持ちの方選ぶやないか
必ず差をつつける誰だって差をつつけるで
さらに授業のことは霊霊の
よ霊っていうのが何のためにあるの和を
持ってとしとなす和は何のためにあるの
真歩のためにあるんだこれが分からん人が
を持って唐とナスを訳すとみんな仲良く
しろてそれが素晴らしいんだっていう
そんな程度に近解釈できんわねだけど霊と
は何か和とは何かが分かればそんな
ちゃんちゃらおかしい意味ではない非常に
重要な意味を含んどるんだ結局しっかり霊
を身につけよう和の能力を身につけよと
いうことになる霊というのは自分及び相手
の能力を正しく知ることだ自分はこの程度
だな同じことやってみ野球でもあれでも
自分がやったらバッと降ったってナイヤ
ゴロしか打てないナイヤフライしか打て
ない大谷にはホームランばっかり打つ
あいつはすげえやつだという尊敬できる
やろだから霊で己れの能力を知るとその差
が分かるその差から端が出るんだ論語見て
ごらん恥ありてかつ至る恥が人間を進歩さ
せる恥を描くことはいいこと恥を描かせる
ことはいいことそれで進歩するんやも相手
が体罰でもしるということでも恥を欠か
せるという意味が大きいやろ昔なしるは
いかどうしも叱らんといかん時は職員室に
呼んでこっそりと叱れなんて言っとったわ
ねせっかくの恥を書くチャンスやから
みんなの前で力もっと大きな恥がかける
じゃんもっと大きく進歩するじゃんそれが
いかんと言い出したいかに物事が分かって
ないか精神というものがいかに分かって
ないか解明してないかがよう分かるわね
JA
[音楽]